salve youtuber sempre venuti ad una
nuova recensione
alzi la mano chi non ha mai visto il
cartone animato di kenshiro avete
presente quello che davano in canali
oscuri tipo italia 7 gold o
telesubalpina credo proprio di sì ma per
i pochissimi infedeli che non sanno di
cosa sto parlando
ve lo faccio spiegare da qualcuno che ne
sa più di me d'aria o cosa c'è cosa vuoi
cosa urli senti qua
volevo sapere se ti andava una
collaborazione completamente inutile per
spiegherà la gente cos'è che in giro e
poi levati dalle palle e temi viene a
rompere i [ __ ] a casa mia solamente
per questa collaborazione seri e che
pensi che io ti dica assistono perché
sei questo grandioso b dell'ami fava si
ok
che dire di ken il guerriero questo
manga ma soprattutto questo personaggio
ha caratterizzato la vita di intere
generazioni soprattutto la generazione
degli anni 80 che si è fatta contigui
rasponi a due mani sulle tecniche dei
maestri che ho chiuso
ho amato tantissimo il manga di ken il
guerriero per di valori martiri
sacrifici e di pedate implosive nei
[ __ ]
molti dei manga di oggi dovrebbero
imparare tantissimo da cannes il
guerriero perché è un fumetto che è
riuscito a fondere l'azione più pura con
una storia appassionante anche molto
competente è stato fatto anche un anime
tratto da cani guerriero che hanno
trasmesso in italia sul gold 7 mi pare
insomma non è un granché anche per
l'epoca e poi il doppiaggio faceva un po
schifo diciamo che la un sembrava
parlasse corrotti
grazie dario ora sparisce comunque farò
il mio palle motion si tratta così la
gente ma basta co sta storia
poi a sei proprio un fallito ci
rivediamo all'inferno
sono venuto qui per salvare giulia da
voi dannate canaglia il mio nome è
dunque ringraziamo dario sempre molto
gentile
il film che voglio recensire oggi e fist
of the north star un film del 1995
diretto da tony ram del regista che
prima ha diretto e il razer 2 e voi è
finito fare qualche episodio dei power
ranger in space qualcosa è andato storto
nella sua carriera
sarà mica questo live action di kenshiro
probabile
[Musica]
il film inizia con una voce fuori campo
che ci racconta cosa succede in questo
periodo
[Musica]
ma facciamo subito la conoscenza di
kenshiro il nostro protocolla sono quei
cosi dovrebbero essere le cicatrici a
forma di costellazione sul petto di ken
ma sembrano più che altro dei pezzi di
wurstel
[Musica]
ok no sembra una fusione tra gli occhi
stanchi di ben stiller e la mascella
d'acciaio di ridge forrester non è
carismatico non è profondo non è cattivo
e un manichino dei grandi magazzini un
po triste questa cosa due secondi dopo
diamo un volto al narratore il padre di
ken interpretato da niente popò di meno
che malcolm mcdowell
come hai fatto a finire in questo
abominio non si sa ma non c'è da
preoccuparsi tanto 4 secondi dopo entra
sheen che lo uccide sparandogli in
faccia ma è logico perché colpirlo con
una delle 800.000 mosse mortali della
scuola della croce del sud quando puoi
fare molto prima così io sono il maestro
della croce del sud ma ti sparo perché
mi pagano per seguire il copione
fatemi dire una cosa qui scrivendo la
recensione non avevo idea di come
prenderlo il film nel senso devo
prenderlo da fan e continuare a
paragonarlo al anime al fumetto
oppure devo prenderlo come film a sé
stante perché comunque in tutti e due i
casi fa schifo ma andiamo avanti
saltiamo un anno e finiamo nella città
della croce del sud il cui imperatore
sheen vuole conquistare il mondo poco
più in là a paradise valley mentre la
gente cerca di sopravvivere
facciamo la conoscenza di bart e l'idv
vi ricordate i due ragazzini compagni di
viaggio di ken
solo che qui bart si chiama bat ayin
invece di essere muta e cieca non è un
problema né ma non capisco il perché ad
un certo punto vengono attaccati dagli
uomini della croce del sud che arrivano
sparano danno fuoco a qualcosa e vanno
via così per sport e come se non
bastasse inizia a piovere acido intanto
kevin in cosplay da cappuccetto rosso
chiede riparo in una baracca
la mattina dopo 3 furbacchioni rapinano
proprio quella baracca è finalmente
giunta l'ora di far vedere al mondo cosa
sa fare cappuccetto rosso
che gli serve il tuo aiuto
[Applauso]
vai così ora sì che assomiglia al vero
che in giro sto per commuovermi schifo
era quello era nomi che 100 colpi del tu
sei già morto zaia o ma per favore
vi ricordate com'era all'originale
[Risate]
cavolo
esatto qui viene rappresentato malissimo
secondo me metà dei pugni neanche lo
colpisce lo sfiora appena lo so lo so
che non bisognerebbe paragonarlo
all'anima ma fa troppo schifo e non ti
da banco la soddisfazione di fartelo
vedere esplodere ti illude con la testa
che si gonfia e poi ottimo lavoro film
prima che odiavo ora vorrei proprio
spezzarti le tibie come un bastone
ottimo lavoro sheen del suo palazzo
ospita un maestro della scuola di nanto
prima lo invita poi la pesta a sangue
ecco perché qui fai un minimo di effetto
speciale e con il pelatone di prima no
utile però tutta questa scena qui è
grazie per avermelo fatto vedere nel
frattempo raffaella carrà si rifugia in
casa dibatte league loro tornano lo
trovano lui guarisce linee dalla cecità
facendo nulla
e riparte nel deserto ok prima di tutto
del cartone che aiuta lina ricominciare
a parlare ma a guarire dalla cecità come
toccandole le tempie cosea anche dei
superpoteri adesso secondo sono io il
film sembra un'enorme accozzaglia di
scene random sono tutte situazioni
sconnesse una dall'altra
ora vediamo gilles con giulia si dicono
due fasi pompate a caso e cambio ora ci
sono i sopravvissuti di paradise valley
che dicono frasi pompate a caso e cambio
ecco un'idea pazzerelle sbarazzina
date un senso alle scene ma sai come
finché ti ostini a voler fare un film su
un cartone che conta oltre 150 episodi
che vuoi aspettarti a proposito di dare
un senso alle cose nella scena dopo che
si risveglia in una discarica e vede lo
zombie di suo padre uscire dal terreno
[Musica]
no non state avendo un allucinazione
causata da infarto
e proprio lo zombie del padre che esce
dal terreno gli dice le solite due frasi
stereotipate pompatissima e sparisce
nella ere era un fantasma
era una visione che era iniziato a farsi
di metanfetamina chi lo sa
fatto sta che inizia ad allenarsi e il
film ci ricorda che è stato scilla a
provocargli le ferite sul corpo e che
gli ha rapito giulia bat lo segue ma
viene beccato da degli scagnozzi di
sheen che vengono subito sconfitti da
ken è uno di questi
a non ci crederete mai una foto di
giulia attaccata alla giacca
[Musica]
perché è come se i dipendenti di
mediaworld indossassero maglie con la
foto di bill gates e grazie a ciò che
capisce che giulia è ancora viva visto è
il primo accenno di trama ed è una
cagata apocalittica
intanto paradise viene invasa lin cerca
di ribellarsi inutilmente così decidono
di ucciderla non ci credo che sto per
dirlo con una ghigliottina macerata al
mare la radio al 3d per questo
[Musica]
la logica di questo film è insuperabile
il padre di kenshiro viene ucciso con
una pistolettata una innocua bambina da
una ghigliottina non fa una grinza
gli rivela che kim sta per arrivare
quindi la catturano sheen cerca di
entrare nelle grazie di giulia che non
se lo caga proprio neanche di pezza i
brutti ceffi interrogano l'ing
usando il loro bestioni più grosso
armato di palla chiodata è solo una
bambina non ti servono ghigliottine e
uomini giganti per torturarla ma che
problema avete
[Applauso]
a lui oscilla la gabbia non vorrei che
la scilla
va bene tipo pupazzo da una scatola
spunta came che gli rompe l'osso del
collo
intanto la piccola ragade venneri
catturata e che palle ma a sto giro e
batte che la salva ma in cambio si
prendono a coltellate in pancia dopo
altre mille coreografie lente e mosse
muoiono tutti bat compreso
molto molto triste cosa
[Musica]
cosa succede
ma cosa sto guardando prima gli appare
come zombie e poi attraverso ii e in
questo preciso istante
potete notare come il film si sia
completamente [ __ ] ho perso le
pochissime speranze che avevo per questa
robaccia ormai è completamente andata
basta l'unico sopravvissuto dei balordi
tornato a casa chissà come al palazzo di
sheen decide di stuprare giulia ma
perché tutte le persone dei mondi post
apocalittici sono sessualmente frustrati
le guerre atomiche hanno distrutto anche
le bambole gonfiabili che riesce
finalmente ad arrivare tipo mezz'ora
dopo batte qualche scagnozzo base e
arriva al boss di fine livello
[Musica]
oh oh sì ma non me lo avevi detto non
sapevo che alla croce del sud
praticassero anche il sado e lascia fare
il vecchio gilles birbantello il
combattimento non è niente di speciale
che è strano che se le prende per bene e
gilles cerca di finirlo colpendolo al
petto e facendogli esplodere le braccia
no
perché in qualche modo sono collegate
non fatevi domande sembra tutto finito
finché che non vedo una radice piantata
nel cemento da giulia e capisce che
forse c'è ancora speranza per il mondo
come no un sacco di speranza proprio si
rialza lo riempie di calci in faccia e
con un rookie che neanche van damme bei
vecchi tempi
lo batte giulia scappa e si unisce alla
sua anima gemella mezza distrutta e
grazie al cielo fine fine fine fine fini
fine io odio questo film l'ho odiato la
prima volta che l'ho visto e l'ho odiato
adesso che ho dovuto a recensirlo fatevi
un regalo
evitate non va bene neanche come film
brutto questo io come al solito vi
ringrazio tutti gli iscritti tutti i
commenti tutti i complimenti che mi fate
tutto il supporto infinito e ci vediamo
ad una prossima recensione
sono venuto qui per salvare giulia da
bond annate canaglia il mio nome cascino